et nous sommes avec Anastasia
chapovskina maître de conférence en
géopolitique à Sciences Po présidente du
signe tank eastern Circle et spécialiste
des relations Europe Russie Anastasia
shapowskina bonsoir merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce soir sur France 24
cette visite de Joe Biden à Kiev c'est
la première du président américain
depuis le début de ce conflit c'est
aussi la première d'un président
américain en Ukraine depuis 2008 elle
est très symbolique effectivement déjà
il faut d'abord placer cette visite dans
le cadre des objectifs de la politique
interne américaine pour moi ça signifie
le début de la campagne présidentielle
électorale par Joe Biden qu'il lance pas
dans un des États-Unis mais qui lance
directement à l'étranger en mettant
aussi son image comme un président qui
n'a pas peur d'aller accueillir sans que
même l'accompagnement par les
hélicoptères de son cortège présidentiel
quand même à en fait sans précédent pour
un président américains toujours
accompagné par une mesure de sécurité
beaucoup plus renforcée et surtout que
là il y avait des alertes au moment même
où le président américain était acquis
afin il y avait des alertes à la au
bombardement qui ont été liées au fait
que les avions de chasse russes sont
partis des bases militaires russes
pendant cette même moment donc est
vraiment c'est pour ça que à chaque fois
que ça observait les allers se
déclenchent qui est juste déplacer avant
entrant pendant 10 heures donc pas un
avion comme normalement est le cas parce
que bien sûr l'espace aérien est fermé
et donc c'est que même c'est-à-dire que
c'est un message qui a envoyé à
l'intérieur on ces opposants mais aussi
à surtout aux personnes qui qui
regardent qui peut peut-être easytes et
surtout à sa base de supporters que Joe
Biden c'est pas juste un vieillard qui
est en train de mourir mais c'est un
président qui a le courage et qui se
positionne en tant que président fort en
allant aussi y compris donc dans dans le
pays dans dans l'Ukraine aujourd'hui et
c'est une manière de rassurer aussi
ses alliés et les Ukrainiens alors que
justement en interne certains
républicains aujourd'hui au congrès sont
de plus en plus frileux à donner de
l'argent
à Kiev à soutenir militairement sans
réserve l'Ukraine là je pense que cette
le fait que y aller c'est pas pour
récupérer le pignon des républicains qui
hésitent mais plutôt pour se mettre en
concurrent avec peut-être d'autres des
opposants républicains qui sont plutôt
dans le domaine stream et qui
n'hésiteront pas pour les raisons que je
vais je veux créer tout à l'heure mais
pour montrer que lui il est aussi du
côté de tout ce qui est le complexe
militaire industriel américain parce que
avec les annonces de dernier budget
militaire des États-Unis qui que même
surplombe même le budget le plus haut
pendant les guerres de l'Irak on peut
bien imaginer que l'intérêt de cet
argent que même qui va être dépensé à la
maison qui va tout dépenser aux
États-Unis n'est pas que les intérêts
démocrates mais aussi des intérêts des
républicains parce que toute cette
immense
compris militaire qui est aussi un des
plus puissants lobby aux États-Unis se
trouve partout aux États-Unis d'un tout
différentes états ce qui explique que
chaque sénateur et chaque gouverneur
n’importe le parti politique aura de
l'intérêt que cet argent soit dépenser
celui et donc je pense que là c'est
c'est une interprétation simpliste de la
politique américaine de dire que les
républicains sont contre les démocrates
sont pour l'Ukraine non tout le monde
pour avoir dépensé le plus de l'argent
possible pour le secteur militaire parce
que c'est la création des implants
internes et c'est la renforcement de
l'image des États-Unis y compris dans le
plan géopolitique pas seulement dans les
yeux des alliés de l'OTAN de l'Ukraine
de la Russie mais aussi surtout dans les
yeux de la Chine qui est aperçu par les
États-Unis comme le et la Chine on va en
reparler tout à l'heure vous restez avec
nous Anastasia shapowskina j'aimerais
qu'on fasse un point à présent sur la
situation sur le terrain dans l'est de
l'Ukraine alors que Joe Biden a annoncé
tout à l'heure de nouvelles aides
militaires pour Kief à zapporija dans le
du pays on retrouve notre envoyé spécial
Pauline Godard Pauline bonsoir
Aujourd'hui sur le terrain les
Ukrainiens ils sont surtout sur la
défensive même s'ils tiennent leur
position des Ukrainiens qui manque de
matériel et qu'ils font savoir à chaque
jour
oui le manque de munitions le manque
d'armes le manque de char c'est ce dont
nous parle les soldats
Ukrainiens sur le terrain nous nous
sommes rendus dans le Dombas et nous
étions à moins de 7 km de la ligne de
front alors impossible pour moi de vous
redire exactement où nous étions pour
des raisons de sécurité pour les
militaires nous avons suivi un équipage
de chars des tankistes ils nous ont donc
montré d'abord leur char qui est bien
caché dans la forêt ils font partie de
la deuxième ligne défensive c'est-à-dire
qu'ils sont prêtes à intervenir si la
première ligne de front si les Russes
passent cette première ligne de front
alors ils nous ont et bien montrer ses
chars qui sont pour la plupart des thés
64 c'est char date de l'Union soviétique
ils ont plus de 50 ans et c'est vrai que
quand vous voyez ces chars et bien ils
sont très vétustes ils fonctionnent mais
pas très bien il y a une technologie
manquante une nouvelle technologie dont
il nous part pour être plus efficace ils
nous ont expliqué ces soldats et bien
passé plus de 70% de leur temps réparer
ses chars et non à combattre et ce temps
et bien il aimerait ils aimeraient bien
le passer à plus combattre et être plus
efficace encore une fois alors ils nous
ont dit espérer désespérément finalement
espérer l'arrivée des chars léopard 2
qui ont été promis par les Occidentaux à
l'Ukraine ils nous ont dit que grâce à
ses chars et bien ils pourraient enfin
peut-être continuer à repousser les
Russes et enfin aussi rentrer dans leur
famille car ça c'est quelque chose qui
revient évidemment tout le temps c'est
le fait de cette victoire cette victoire
à laquelle il croit énormément merci
beaucoup Pauline Godard en direct de
zapporica dans le sud-est de l'Ukraine
Anastasia shapowskina on vient
d'entendre notre envoyer spécial
l'Ukraine a beaucoup de matériel vétus
l'Ukraine a besoin de munitions d'armes
d'ailleurs le chef de l'OTAN la semaine
dernière a dit qu'il fallait davantage
de munitions pour soutenir le pays Joe
Biden tout à l'heure il a annoncé une
nouvelle de 500 millions de dollars
est-ce que tout ça ça va être suffisant
alors qu'aujourd'hui l'Ukraine elle se
bat notamment à batmouth elle en a
besoin maintenant est-ce que ça ne va
pas mettre trop de temps tout ça arriver
c'est promesses occidentales c'est ça le
souci le plus important c'est déjà c'est
pas le premier fois qu'on entend les
rapports des gens à l'Est notamment de
fond de l'est donc qui réclame que il va
compter leur mission et ça c'est ça
montre la faiblesse vraiment flagrante
de soutien donc des alliés de l'OTAN et
ça explique pourquoi Zelinski a dû se
déplacer lui-même pour aller partout en
Europe pour aller aux États-Unis même on
risque c'est une sécurité importante
parce que c'est le seul moyen de de
soutenir le soutien de maintenir le
soutien mais c'est vrai que là dans tout
ce qu'on a entendu dans ces dernières
semaines sur le soutien des chars déjà
d'un côté il y a des noms des chiffres
qui sont annoncés qui doivent encore
faire la somme de 300 chars demandés par
le côté ukrainien euh on doit se
rappeler que les Russes ont perdu le
nombre d'estimé des chars entre 2000 et
3000 depuis le début de la guerre ils
ont quand même encore quelques milliers
dans leur stocks donc là on a quand même
pas du tout dans les mêmes de grandeur
mais les charrues on a vu ils sont plus
quand ils se sont moins bons que que les
chats que les chars
occidentaux mais que même on n'est pas
du tout dans la même heure de grandeur
c'est la première chose deuxième chose
c'est que bien sûr le délai de livraison
qui vont prendre du temps de très livré
et les chars s'ils vont venir tout seul
c'est c'est c'est un canard qui s'expose
donc dans le Marais dans le sens que le
char doit être accompagné que même par
tout ton système donc militaire qui
travaille ensemble y compris le système
des avions et c'est pour ça que cette
demande des avions de support aérien
revient à répétition ça les Occidentaux
ils restent frileux sur cette question
des avions notamment les États-Unis à
chaque fois les les explications bien
sûr tout le monde regarde les États-Unis
pour prononcer pour sur le sujet parce
que derrière c'est les États-Unis qui
vont remplir les avions manquants les
chers manquantes par exemple les
Allemands ont attendu la décision des
États-Unis exactement exactement
et ensuite les Allemands des filles on
s'est reculé sur leur propre propos en
disant qu'on va faire la passe etc donc
du coup c'est toujours comme si donc il
y a pas de manque de du
professionnalisme des militaires des
personnes motivées et des personnes qui
apprennent très vite de côté ukrainien
mais il y a cette manque de soin de soi
la manque de décisivité donc de de de la
part occidentale je pense que avec le
visite d'aujourd'hui c'est très
difficile à imaginer que BAE dans se
déplacer juste pour faire des photos
avec Céline ski j'espère bien que il y a
des choses qui ont été décidées mais qui
n'ont pas été annoncées pour les raisons
très claires et très simple et donc
parce que sinon elle ira aucune raison
d'y aller pour Biden même et pourrait
bien envoyer
quelques photos mais
même si les news sont des meilleurs
possibles même si on a quelques
espérances que peut-être elle est avec
des chars les avions vont venir etc que
même ces délai c'est ça qui sur quoi
joue la Russie aujourd'hui parce que la
Russie est en train de envoyer des
vagues des vagues des personnes sans
compter
en face à au nombre de munitions comptés
aujourd'hui avoir repris un village
d'ailleurs près de près de bac mouth
vous évoquez la Chine tout à l'heure
justement la question de livraison
d'armes dans ce conflit elle est au cœur
de nouvelles tensions entre les
États-Unis et Pékin depuis ce weekend le
chef de la diplomatie américaine Anthony
blinken accuse la Chine de vouloir
fournir un soutien létal à Moscou la
Chine elle dénonce des fausses
informations on voit ça avec Axel Simon
on en reparle juste après
jusqu'à présent la Chine s'est bien
gardée de fournir un soutien matériel
direct à la Russie mais les États-Unis
craignent que cela ne soit en train de
changer des dimanches en marge de la
conférence sur la sécurité à Munich le
secrétaire d'État américain affirmé
craindre que la Chine soit sur le point
de fournir des armes à la Russie des
craintes réitérer ce lundi en Turquie
cela aurait des conséquences réelles sur
nos relations si la Chine fournissait un
soutien létal à la Russie dans cette
guerre d'agression contre l'Ukraine
nous avons des craintes sérieuses que la
Chine envisage de le faire
des accusations rejetées par la Chine
qui accuse à son tour les États-Unis de
maître de l'huile sur le feu la réponse
de Pékin Washington n'est sans équivoque
restez en dehors de nos relations avec
Moscou
ce sont les États-Unis et non la Chine
qui fournissent des armes sur le champ
de bataille les États-Unis n'ont pas à
nous dire quoi faire nous n'acceptons
pas qu'il pointe du doigt les relations
entre nous et la Russie et encore moins
qu'ils exercent des pressions
côté européen aussi on met en garde la
Chine voilà nous disons que pour nous ce
serait une ligne rouge de notre relation
le ministre des Affaires étrangères
chinois m'a dit que la Chine nous
fournirait rien il n'avait pas
l'intention de le faire mais nous
resterons vigilants
depuis bientôt un an la Chine a refusé
de condamner l'agression russe et même
de qualifier l'offensive d'invasion ou
d'agression mais elle a plusieurs fois
exprimé son soutien à Moscou face aux
sanctions occidentales
Anastasia chapochkina est-ce qu'il faut
prendre ses affirmations des États-Unis
au sérieux quel intérêt aurait la Chine
d'entrer dans ce conflit d'aider
directement Moscou il y a deux écoles de
pensée par rapport à la Chine déjà
l'école de français donc on peut dire
rue Sophie qui depuis même 2014 mais
surtout depuis
l'invasion totale 2022 a toujours rêvé
que la Chine va salir avec le Moscou
donc pour revoir complètement l'ordre
mondial et la deuxième école de pensée
donc c'est surtout pour tous les
accidents qui espérait toujours surtout
depuis l'invasion totale que pour les
Chine que même ce serait
ça signifierait aller trop loin et qui a
retrouvé le confort en observant ce que
la Chine faisait autour de Tevan d'abord
pendant la même temps que la Russie a
commencé l'émotion de l'Ukraine le chien
entouré tout le Tavanes pour ses propres
exercices militaires et ensuite et la
retirer cette roue à tout le monde a de
regarder on entend plus de parler depuis
des mois c'est-à-dire la Chine a compris
son le son que les sanctions économiques
seront trop dures et donc elle veut plus
s'emmêler néanmoins depuis quelques mois
c'est pas que depuis quelques semaines
mais depuis quelques mois on a observé
l'augmentation de tout ce qui est
l'agitation de la de la part de la Corée
du Nord par rapport à la Russie surtout
les livraisons d'armes et de mémoire la
Corée du Nord en tant que acteur
indépendant géopolitique n'existe pas
dans le sens elle n'a produit pas
énormément d'armes tout seul c'est pas
un pouvoir économique c'est pas un
billet t'aider énorme donc on peut
supposer que tout ce que fait que le
Corée du Nord même la raison simple
et donc c'est à dire que déjà la porte
est ouverte elle ne t'a pas été beaucoup
refermé l'échine donc si si ça peut même
même le film peut tout nier et l'accord
et du nom va être cette porte pour les
transfert des armes si jamais le
deuxième école de pensée se trompe et la
Chine réfléchi pendant un an elle a pesé
les pros et les contre et il a décidé
que pour elle c'était pas ça voulait pas
le coup d'attendre que la guerre
continue depuis l'épuisement des
États-Unis etc et ensuite d'essayer de
quoi faire avec Tavan mais de prendre ce
moment maintenant de miser sur sa propre
capacité industrielle de production et
de entrée dans le dans le conflit direct
on peut dire avec les États-Unis en
utilisant les Russes et les Ukrainiens
comme les proxy pour cette guerre
globale parce que pour la Chine les
Russes ce ne sont pas des égaux c'est
plutôt les États-Unis qui est le
stratégique et le adversaire stratégique
ce serait une en face à face
à face merci beaucoup Anastasia
proustina d'avoir été notre invité sur
France 24 pour revenir sur cette visite
de Joe Biden ce matin à Kiev visite
surprise et